ah ouais c'est vrai que là jeenie
moisose ma cam oui allez euh on va
enchaîner avec le deuxième buz du jour C
un foo incroyable vendredi matin détenu
de 24 ans de Florine Merogis s'est évadé
lors une sortie au musée du kbranly à
Paris euh ce n'est pas la première fois
que ça se produit ça arrive même assez
régulièrement on regarde ces
images cette évasion dans des
circonstance peu commune un détenu de
fleur merogi s'est évadé lors d'une
sortie au musée du kbranly à Paris le
détenu de 24 ans particip à une visite
avec d'autres détenus encadrés par des
surveillants pénitentiaires mi-septembre
deux détenus de ce même centre
pénitentiaire séit évadé lors d'une
soirée sortie pardon organisée en forêt
de Fontainebleau avant d'être retrouvé
quelques semaines plus tard bon alors
Gilles Verdez ça fait des ordres mais
c'est exceptionnel les prisons
françaises sont extrêmement sûres il y a
eu les dernières années 10 13 et 16
évasions par an il y a de plus en plus
de détenus donc voilà c'est regrettable
pardon dans les autres pays dans les
autres pays il y en a plus comment tu
sais 10 10 en 2021 13 en 2022 16 en 202
dans les autres pays je sais pas je
crois que en Pologne en polne par pas de
la polne par la moi je pense que aux
États-Unis je pense qu' beaucoup Mo sont
enchaîné Mo on a un problème en France
c'est que 7 % des postes sont vacants
des postes pour être gardien de
surveillant de prison parce que
évidemment le métier n'est absolument
pas attractif c'est pas assez payé pour
les risques qu's prennent pour la
fatigue qu'ils ont pour le voilà et et
par ailleurs normalement c'est un un un
gardien de prison pour de et demi
prisonniers là c'est pour TR la question
c'est comment on s'occupe des détenus en
fait est-ce qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'opinion on a envie qu'un détenu aille
faire une sortie au musé on a la
question mais on moi quand on a reçu
Monsieur boton ici c'était d'ailleurs
passionnant parce que lui aussi c'est
quelqu'un de TER contrairement à moi qui
ne suis pas de terrain donc je ne
connais pas donc lui il est légitime
comme tout à l'heure Patrice était
légitime à nous parler de la rue
Monsieur boton légitime à parler de la
prison ce que je ne suis pas mais il
nous a dit Queen gros les gens qui
étaient en prison il sort sortait pire
que ce qui rentrait parce qu'en fait la
prison malgré tout fabrique encore plus
de la délinquence que ce que c'était au
début mais malgré tout est-ce que nous
aujourd'hui en tant que citoyen on a
envie qu'un détenu je sais pas Ali ça
dépend moi ça dépend pour quelle peine
ça dépend pour quelle peineis désolé moi
moi moi j'ai j'ai je le dis voilà j'ai
des gens que je connais bien qui qui qui
ont fait des qui ont pas fait voilà qui
ont fait c'est pas des c'est pas des
violeurs
c'est des gens qui on pas des crimes
de
an parce que vous avez tué
quelqu' un violeur ou un pédophile je
veux pas le
voir Mo pour pointeur non je suis désolé
lein violeur pour moi il a pas
d'activité pour Mo pour moi pour moi il
a plus aucun pour moi un violeur ou un
pédophile il a plus aucun loisir c'est
fini Mme pas la tél il ve dire qu'il
faut qu'il ne sorte jamais oui pas
forcément le
cas moi moi je moi je su moi je suis
pour ça moi je suis pour ça je suis pour
qu'un un violeur un pédophile un comme
ça pour moi il a aucun loisir après il y
a j'ai des voilà j'ai j'ai des potes moi
qui ont fait des conneries voilà mais
ils ont pas ils sont pas làdedans voilà
eux je suis désolé ça me fait plaisir de
les voir faire une sortie au kbran parce
que ils ont envie deérer ils ont envie
de faire autre chose ils ont envie moi
j'ai des potes moi qui était au placard
ils sont je peux vous dire ils sont
beaucoup plus cultivés que moi et ils
ont passé leur temps à lire ils ont ont
passé des années en prison et ils ont
passé leur temps à lire aujourd'hui pr
activités dans la prison à ce moment des
bibliothèques des ateliers des chos
comme ça sur le fond je suis d'accord
avec vous là c'est vrai qu'il éta
condamné à une peine légère 2 ans donc
il fera jamais 2 ans il fera un an on
peut se passer pendant un an d'aller au
musée franchement c'est pas je voyais
pas où il faut bien commme une privation
de liberté si vous avez des sorties
toutes les semaines vous allez une fois
au centre aéré une fois la fête de la
musique une fois au au théâre mais ne
donne pas une fausse image de la prison
ne donne pas l'idée c'est
GIS sore la musi ilé au toilett tu viens
dire 365 jours un an il peut tenir un an
c'est long
an C
48 c'est facile mais on peut aussi ne
pas aller au musée pendant
an rêver de faire une émission où je
fais passer une semaine en prison à des
gars oui on sait qu'on va rester qu'une
semaine c'est plus facile quand même oui
c'est vrai mais bon tu toi tu resteras 2
ans même une semaine il va péter lesême
une semaine dans les vraies conditions
conditions les plus dures de la prison
même une semaine je suis sûr qu'au bout
de 3 jours tu j'arrête je rend c'est une
semè mais moi je suis pour les je suis
pour les activités culturelles mais dans
la prison le musée du kbran c'est
14 quel mépris pour les gens on organise
des sorties de prisonniers en prison
mais mais on délire complètement prison
c'est la punition
les gars les gars les gar g les gar je
dire pour moi TR le truc est simple
c'est au cas par cas
désolis
m'ader
finrap
y a des gars qui ont jamais été RRA sa
qu'après après il y a il y a une c'est
terminé au bout d'un certain temps ou
prescription ça veut dire si on vous
retrouve moi j'ai quelqu'un que que je
connais qui sétait évadé et qui n'a
jamais été retrouvé et là je crois que
la prescription et là est
tombé ils sont souvent même heureux
d'être attattrapé par que la cavale
c'est parfis ils sont content d'être
rrouvé par bon mais ça ça Arve
là où il y en a le plus c'est dans les
régimes de semiliberté et apparent 700
détenus qui profitent de la semiliberté
qui ne rentrent pas en prison voilà là
oui mais sinon moi alors là par rapport
à ce qu'a dit Radouan c'est complètement
dingue de dire on les empêche d'aller au
musée on les empêche la culture
iltion r la culture est-ce que le
français moi quand j'étais plus jeune
j'avais pas les moyens d'aller au musée
c'était 14 € c'est 14 € le musée dubr et
si lui n'a jamais pu aller au musée
est-ce que la prison n'est pas une
occasion pas ou quand j'étais petit j'ai
jamais les
moyall la prison c'est justement
l'occasion pour des pour des gens qui
malheureusement ont été peut-être
contraint de faire un forfait ou autre
et ben de sortir de leurs
condition B mais enfin je crois rêver là
excuse-moi on a parlé hier des SUV une
sortie en famille maintenant de
banlieusard avec quatre enfants ils vont
pas pouvoir ils vont pas pouvoir aller
au musée branl ça va leur coûter
les excuse-moi parce que on en parle
tous les jours des gens qui font
vraiment de la prison déjà maintenant
qui sont sous les barreaux c'est déjà
pas anodin ce sont de toute façon des
des peines avec des des vrais
délinquants je suis désolé je n'ai aucun
souci à ne pas donner d'argent pour que
des gens des prisonniers n'aillent
pasist je n'ai aucun scrupule que je ne
suis désolé la réinsertion excuse-moi
regarde il fait quoi il va au musé
trucateurs et le travail des éducateurs
prison tout ce qu'on veut je suis désolé
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui demander à
nos impô de pay pour qui sont en fin de
peine gamin qui mon avisit uneve
connerie à mon avisêtre AC les
éducateurs et pas avec avec avec les
policiers je pense je te dis honnêtement
il y en a qui font du super boulot
d'accord justement pour réinsérer
certains jeunes réinsérer ceux qui ont
fait une grave erreur et puis voà moi je
te donne mon ressenti je pas envie qu'on
utilise no
impô télpectateur s'il vous plaît les
prisons sont-elles trop laxistes oui
voilà 93% je m'en dout un peu 93% et non
à
6% le sondagechir on va passer au point
people et on va revenir sur énormément
de choses on commence point people avec
une info qui concerne Renault le
chanteur